hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property developer and right now i'm
standing in the middle
of my latest property development site
so you may remember on youtube
i did a video last year and i said i've
just bought a piece of land
the land cost me 330 000 pounds that's
how mrs landcast
i said i was going to build six houses
from scratch and then the
end value was going to be 1.35 million
i said it was going to cost me half a
million pounds to build the houses and
people were saying i can't imagine that
i can't imagine there'd been six houses
and at the time i was saying there's
gonna be three here there's going to be
three here and guess what it's done
so we've got three houses right here
we've got three houses right here
on this little piece of land the values
come in by a chartered valuer at 1.35
million
they're all rented out now they're
renting for around about seven to five
seven hundred and fifty pounds each
uh we're refinancing some selling some
this was structured as a joint venture
agreement which i'll talk through you
really shortly i'll talk through the
figures how it was financed
exactly how much profit i've made and
whenever you do development you always
need a little bit of faith
because you need to be able to see it
first and then make it happen
so when this was just a piece of land i
remember saying there's gonna be
three houses here there's gonna be three
houses here and even people in the
comments were like i can't see there's
enough space for six houses
i can't imagine you're gonna be able to
do it that quick i can't imagine it's
only gonna cost 500 000 pounds well
you don't have to imagine because right
now you can see it okay so this is the
show home
and you've always got to have a show
home but to be honest the way that the
tenants have done the houses up in every
house
um doesn't look massively different to
the show home so
really really nice these ones are a
little bit bigger so these properties
the rent is a little bit higher
so these have been rented out for 750
those back ones will be rented out for
725
which is great um really really nice
just so cute and livable
let's have a little look upstairs
entire stood walk i mean these houses
are so cheap to build
considering we built six houses for 500
grand and they're nice they're modern
they're brand new
good location personally
with these types of new builds i think
it's smarter
to sell them quickly while they're brand
new because here's the thing okay when
you just built a brand new house
it's shiny it's new you can sell it at a
premium
also with the help to buy scheme people
are paying a lot for new builds
refinancing them is an okay option but
for me that was always an exit strategy
if they wouldn't sell
as it happens they are selling like
people are queuing up to buy them to
rent them
but refinancing them what could happen
is you could refinance
pull your money out get it valued really
high which is perfect but then after a
few years when they lose that shiny
new feeling um they drop a little bit of
value
so that's why i've chosen out of the six
houses
the profit i'm getting the profit of
four of them and then my joint venture
partners getting the profit of two of
them
for my four i've chosen i'm selling them
you know i want to sell them and get my
money
put it into a new project put it into
another development site whereas
my joint venture partner he's chosen to
refinance that's what he's looking like
he's gonna do
totally fair enough you know get some
passive income but he's gonna be left
with two houses
you know he didn't put a penny a penny
into this so it just shows that with
development the pie is big enough
for there to be different parties
different people making money as it
happens i was the financer behind this
whole estate
um i've got a million pounds of my money
into this over a million pounds of my
own money into this deal right now
and you know some of those people say
samuel really a millionaire
this this this this estate just this
estate alone i've got over a million
pounds profit cash
no mortgage i didn't get bridging
finance for this deal i didn't borrow
money this was all my own money
and there's over a million pounds equity
in here and you won't find a company's
house
because it's all done um in in my joint
venture party's company in his name
but i'm just i'm just taking the
majority of the profit so it works for
me
and every pretty much every deal that i
do is a joint venture sometimes i'll put
the money in
sometimes someone else will put the
money in but joint ventures are a really
really good way to grow your development
company to grow fast
so this has worked out super well so the
show home is actually the only property
that's not occupied
all of the others are tenanted the
tenants have all given me permission to
go in and film
this one's tenanted this one's tenanted
i'll go and have a quick look to show
you what this
shows the comparable
garden
so why why did i do this as a joint
venture partner
[ __ ] why do i not just you know why
don't i just do all my own things myself
and the answer is
i do do things myself sometimes but i
have so many people coming to me with
opportunities with development
opportunities with sites
so the guy that came to me with this
opportunity was like samuel i've got a
piece of land
you know i've found it i'd love to build
on it i haven't got the money
do you want to put the money in and and
we can do it as a joint venture
and you know we negotiated something 180
000 pounds
in about six to 12 months putting in no
money
absolutely you're not even doing the
work no you're just overseeing the work
i'm gonna make how much will i make
about three hundred thousand twenty
i like about 320 000 i'm putting the
money in
but i'm not putting any time in why say
no i don't want to pay you a percentage
of the profits i'll find my own deal
it might take me six months to find
another deal you know this is ready
it's here it's good i know that the that
my partner
is local he can keep an eye on it for me
it's passive
i haven't got to manage the builders
find the builders keep coming overseeing
anything
you know it's win-win and every joint
venture is different
but if you can find deals like this i'm
interested in joint venturing with you
if you can fund deals like this
sometimes i'll be finding too many deals
i can't fund them all at once so that's
the power and the beauty of joint
venture agreements
there's a lot of people last year when i
announced this piece of land
i haven't been talking about this deal
too much because when i first announced
it people were saying there's no way
you're gonna do that you know you're
gonna build those houses so fast
you know coronavirus and um that you
won't get six what about this what about
that there's no way it's gonna value up
this won't work that won't work
and i just thought actually you know
what i've got a really good team and
you know we've structured the deal well
i did my due diligence before coming on
the deal and i thought well let's just
wait
we'll wait and see what happens and now
it's all finished
the gdv is 1.35 million four of the
houses we've got buyers for
two of them are going to be refinanced
they're all tenanted and the tenants are
really happy
the land was bought for 3 30. the cost
of building everything was 500 000
pounds
that's 8 30 830 grand all in now 1.35
million is the value
that's around about five hundred
thousand pounds half a million pounds
of uplift of profit in the deal so i
think it's been an incredible deal
and uh i'm looking forward to the next
one and i'll be documenting it
hey how you doing how much you pay
7.50 7 45 7 4 5
5 7 25 7 2
5 i'm upset now i thought it was 75th
day
those ones are 750 these ones are 75.
there we have it this place looks
fabulous
we'll see you soon oh you're very
welcome
and it's great to see that the tenants
are really happy like she was like thank
you thank you we love it here
i mean that's really what this is about
sometimes people say greedy landlords
but actually there's a massive shortage
of houses so to build a house
you're not taking away from any
first-time buyers you're not
you're building a house providing a
beautiful home then renting it or
selling it to a first-time buyer
so i actually feel as a property
investor as a property developer
you know not only are we making profit
i'll talk about the money
but also we're actually helping the
country we're helping the economy let's
have a look at this next house
hello hi hello how you doing
lounge two bedrooms upstairs kitchen
nice little tv
little back garden very cute good
area good demand it's a good area right
all right so upstairs this little piece
of land you know it wasn't massive so
these houses
they're not really big but hey
they're nice it reminds me of my first
house
front uh back bedroom little garden
front bedroom
there's something about new builds you
know new builds just have a great feel
and uh you know people want to move them
they into new rent them so and terrace
terrace terrace
and the value of each house is 225.
225 000 pounds and it's right next to
the lincoln hospital so it's a real real
prime spot
when you're buying a piece of land it's
important to be able to say once they're
built
how rentable are these going to be how
saleable are these going to be and it's
proven that they're all very rentable
and saleable
there's an overpopulation of people a
shortage of housing just feels so
satisfying as a property developer
to make money doing doing what you love
but also
helping people providing homes fantastic
feeling
if you if you want to do deals like this
okay you've got to get the knowledge
first
because you can get all the money you
can save save save but if you haven't
got the knowledge
how are you going to be able to add
value there's so much that can go wrong
but won't if you have the knowledge or
if you're joint venturing with people
that have the knowledge
so funny because people say people say
samuel lead sells people dreams
sells people dreams that they can you
know be a property investor or a
developer starting with no money
and i believe that if you've got the
knowledge
to find deals if you've got the skill to
negotiate
but you've not got any money guess what
you can build houses like this
because my joint venture partner trevor
he approached me with this piece of land
he didn't have the money at the time to
buy so we set up a joint venture on this
how much money are you putting into this
deal nothing
nothing i'm putting the money in how
much profit are you hoping to make from
this deal within within the nine months
period
about half a million pounds he didn't
have the money at the time to build but
just because
he he had the knowledge and the skill to
find the land
and he had the contact with the builders
i'm like yeah dude i'll put the money in
i put 830 000 pounds my own hard cash
boom into this into this entire stack i
funded 100
trevor didn't put any money in at all
smart man
good for trevor you know he's taking
about a third of the profit
um as a result so he's made six figures
just over the last year in this estate
and he didn't even do the work himself
he wasn't the project manager he wasn't
a builder he just found the land
put the builders together and presented
the opportunity so for me
like yes in this case this wasn't a no
money down deal for me in this case
i paid for this whole thing this entire
entire estate was paid for by me
but if i didn't have the money okay if i
had no money
all i'd do is i'd find development
opportunities like this
get someone else to put the money in in
fact that's what i often do when i
started out for the first five six years
all my deals were no money down deals
you know so if you're thinking
i haven't got enough money to do it you
don't need the money what you need is
the skill
you know and this this development is
testament to that
and if you've got the skill that's what
i do i train people up
train people how to find deals i write
the checks
samuel souls people dreams i wrote the
checks and to all those neg heads
to all those neckheads that said i
couldn't build six houses
you know it would take too long and what
about coronavirus
the gdv will never be 1.35 million sango
is over egging the figures
guess what it's worth 1.35 million we've
had it valued by an independent
chartered valuer
we've had it valued by an estate agent
we've got people queuing up to buy
i've had four offers around about 200
000 pounds which is a little bit below
market value
but you know what i want my cash back
now fast i want my cash back now fast
see um trevor my joint venture partner
he's getting the profit from the six
houses he put no money in
he's getting the profit basically from
two of the houses
i'm getting the profit from four of the
houses and then i'm getting all of my
money back that i initially put in
that's pretty much how we've structured
it
and with my four houses i don't want to
refinance them
because i know and and listen i'm an up
i'm
i'm an optimist but i have a feeling
this is what normally happens with new
belts i'm just going to say as it is
i have a feeling they're going to dip
they're going to drop in value
so i don't want to refinance and hold on
to them and have them drop in value
they rent seven two five seven fifty
that doesn't excite me
i wanna sell them make my profit if i
sell my four even if i sell them below
market value i'll still get
over a million pounds right now in my
bank from this deal you got to visualize
everything i remember saying
we're going to flatten this kerb we're
going to put electric car chargers on
the outside of the house boom there they
are
it's all done i'm super happy so listen
if you
want to see more videos like this
comment in the comment box let me know
i have projects of my own going on i
have my students having projects going
on
if you want to see more development
videos like this check out this video
right here that's my castle
you know you'll enjoy that that's a big
one that's a long one it's going to take
a very long time to complete
also if you want to hear stories of my
students that are winning in property
you can check out a whole bunch of
interviews and stories right here please
comment below
subscribe you can subscribe right here
and i look forward to seeing you
next time thanks